on retrouve michel c'est logique de
montréal maintenant quand ali qui était
à ottawa pour faire le point sur cette
nouvelle journée de campagne électorale
bonjour à vous deux bonjour alors on
veut vous entendre d'abord sur thomas
mulcair aussi à quel point ç'a été long
mais finalement il le fait il le
préciser sa position sur le port du
niqab aujourd'hui pendant les cérémonies
citoyenneté ont écouté un extrait je
vous entends des personnes ne le dois de
dire une femme ce qu'elle doit porter ou
ne pas porter je suis d'accord avec la
règle existante
selon laquelle une femme portant le
niqab soient tenus de se découvrir avant
d'obtenir sa citoyenneté dans le respect
de ses convictions religieuses et
sincère mais si certaines de ces femmes
sont opprimées
il faut les aider et ce n'est pas en les
privant de leur citoyenneté canadienne
et de leurs doigts qu'on va y arriver
alors on voit justement sur quoi il
quand sa position ça a été long mais a
fini par le faire finalement sur le
droit des femmes sur le droit des femmes
occident occuper l'espace public et on
pondère un peu les inconvénients et les
avantages là les obliger à se découvrir
ici
maintenant j'ai commencé avec vous
est-ce que c'était habile comme position
de la part de monsieur vainqueur
aujourd'hui mais c'était si le reflet de
ce qui les fait entendre déjà depuis
quelques jours et où si ce qu'il avait
déjà dit l'hiver dernier lorsqu'il y
avait eu la première décision mais il
devait leur faire clairement parce que
là il est pris à partie un particulier
par le bloc québécois et c'est son
adversaire numéro un sur le terrain et
donc il devait clarifier sa position et
on met pas tout une façon à la fois de
la confirmer ce un braque et des gens
qui sont contre je suppose l'accord
commun qu'une serment les gens qui sont
farouchement opposés à l'idée que les
femmes puissent garder leur niqab pour
la cérémonie de citoyenneté ou pas bien
c'est de la cérémonie ce mode germain
hop on a perdu maintenant je vous
demande et par leur lynch et dans la
salle et la bascule maintenant
ouais
j'ai un peu d'accord je me disais je
vois pour sur sa pensée ce pas ce qui a
convaincu les gens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui au départ c'est on
n'est pas dans le débat sur la charte
des valeurs ici au qu'on a bien connu au
québec où on parce que là on parlait de
gens qui travaillaient dans la fonction
publique qui avait un voile ouais ouais
ok watts urbain et mais qui
travaillaient qui était qu'ils étaient
des fermiers dans un hôpital quelque
chose comme ça et donc acquis qu'ils
allaient perdre leur travail si on
appliquait la chambre va là on est sur
le niqab donc la figure complètement
voyais et on le voit dans les résultats
de sondages en résultat de boussole
électorale dans des sortes de choses
comme ça où que ça ne passe pas et il ya
peut-être au-delà désir est là dessus
gemalto raison ceci quelques
appréhensions des canadiens ont proposé
des beaucoup il ya aussi un espèce de
bruit de fond en arrière qui dit quelque
part faut qu'il y ait une limite
d'ailleurs les limites il existe à
l'article 1 de la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés
quelque part il faut une limite pour
beaucoup de gens la limite c'est
justement le niqab
oui alors maintenant shell avait repris
le fil de vos pensées pendant vous
n'êtes jamais servi je pense que le bien
fait ça mais j'en prends maintenant avec
vous maintenant est ce que c'est pour
toujours perdant perdant pour cette
question là pour monsieur marquée au
québec justement y a pas moyen de s'en
sortir
à mon avis et c'est difficile de s'en
sortir à moins que certaines personnes
qui ont quand même des gens qui le
réflexe de dire je suis opposé
j'aimerais qu'on trouve une solution
pour que ce soit interdit
mais je voudrais que ça se fasse dans
les noms mais sans que ce sens que sa
surface en prenant en otage un petit
groupe de femmes qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas avec elles et donc et donc il ya des
gens peut-être qu'ils devront être
inclus quand même l'écouter mais il
faudra voir si c'est ça qui décidera qui
sera le facteur décisif dans le choix
électoral des gens de toutes sortes
d'autres enjeux qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
est-ce que ça va se tasser un peu s'il a
fait de la campagne on verra la question
est évidemment de savoir comment les
autres partis surtout bon les
conservateurs et le bloc qui exploite ce
sujet là avec beaucoup plus de vigueur
s'ils vont continuer à le faire je pense
qu'il l'a langer pour monsieur mal qu'un
mais il ne peut pas dire une chose et
son contraire dons
il ya aussi dans le reste du pays un
point de vue qui est peut-être moins
campé au québec mais il ya quand même
une majorité de gens au canada qui sont
quand même d'accord avec l'idée que les
personnes ne puisse pas prêter serment
le visage couvert
on peut être certain qu aux débats de
main et monsieur duceppe et monsieur
harper vont partir là dessus dans ces
clercs et ils ont rien à perdre parce
que monsieur manquait tellement en avant
au québec bien que dans les derniers
jours s'abaisser là mais il sait faire
qui vont pas acquis que ça va être la
leur en jeu dans ce débat là qu'on
puisse évoquer le débat justement michel
est ce que c'est important justement
qu'il a clarifié sa position avant qu'on
plonge dans le débat là il est clair la
position de problème si elle n'est pas
en accord avec ce que la très large
majorité des gens qui veulent percer la
peau on peut pas dire que ça pour ça bon
dans le taux et la manière qu'il est
pris aujourd'hui parce que les faits
sont à l'intérieur de moment où il
faisait vraiment un discours l'a
carrément alors on l'a vu très calme
très en contrôle dans ce discours c'est
important aussi cette manière ses traits
sont fins oui c'était important tabac
d'ailleurs vous le vous le notez les
faits ce discours à 100 tout les décors
électoraux qu'ils utilisent
habituellement c'est un podium note
ils étaient des drapeaux qui était
derrière la salle était son bref c'était
fait avec beaucoup de sérénité donc avec
l'idée de projeter quand même une image
de chef d'état de quelqu'un qui se met
au dessus de la mêlée c'est aussi ça son
objectif aujourd'hui de montrer que lui
se mettait au dessus de la mêlée qui ne
l'est pas exploiter le sujet est donc
oui ce ton là est important a évidemment
à la veille du débat ça permet de donner
une autre image
mais une fois qu'on va être dans le
cadre du débat on verra demain mais
demain il sera pas seul par contre à
défendre une position similaire monsieur
trudeau aussi mais c'est lui qui a le
plus à perdre si ça dérape sur ce sujet
là est-ce que ça n'est ce pas justement
vous parlez de monsieur trudeau de créer
comme on dirait une sorte de confusion
un an barolle pour les électeurs c'est à
dire de s'y retrouver entre la la
position de monsieur manquez pas la
proposition de monsieur trudeau sur la
question du niqab parce que
essentiellement ils ont l'air de marcher
dans le même sens tig
mais ils se battent dans le même sens la
position de monsieur trudeau est à peu
près un peu de choses de abdoun ans près
la même que monsieur que monsieur
mulcair
celui ci ont marqué ce matin est allé
voir denis coderre ont fait pas tout à
fait dire que denis colère que c'est
quelqu'un qui est un excité sur ces
choses là il y avait été très posé les
très ferme contre la charte des valeurs
du québec à l'époque lui dire écoute et
la limite elle est honni câble 60 moi je
trouve que ça n'a pas de bon sens moi je
le dis toujours dans une campagne
électorale des politiciens fédéraux
devraient coûter les maires parce qu'on
aurait à terre fizi ils sentent que
leurs citoyens disent on va passer
maintenant une annonce qui a été faite
aujourd'hui par steven blainey qui était
avant les élections ministre de la
sécurité publique alors collège
militaire de saint jean qui va voir un
autre volet formation cjt ce soit de
niveau universitaire bret ont ré un
petit peu au collège tel qu'on le
connaît par le passé mais il ya quand
même déjà fort longtemps à qui il
s'adresse à qui il s'adresse cette
annonce aux électeurs de saint jean
aussi précisé max anstie j'écris ces
lignes
c'était un enjeu qui avait fait mal aux
libéraux dans cette région là lorsqu'il
avait décidé de le fermer le bloc en a
fait ses choux gras pendant des années
je pense que oui en europe et être
conscient qu'on peut arriver à grignoter
un peu là mais c'est aussi parce qu'on
cherche à jouer la carte justement du
bilinguisme de respect des francophones
et comme vous voyez c'est le ministre la
sécurité publique et non le ministre de
défense qui était parce que c'est lui
qui est mise du québec à la famille et
de la défense bien aidé de l'alberta
c'était une opération pour essayer de
l'année des votes
mais michel c'était très chirurgicale ne
peut-être pas pour le comté de saint
jean moi je vous dirais que c'était très
chirurgicale pour le comté de louis
saint laurent à québec où le candidat
gérard deltell qui leur candidat vedette
est en perte de vitesse c'est que c'est
le côté où se trouve la base de
de valcartier et où il ya eu la plus
grande propension de militaires au
québec et c'est clair qu'ils veulent
gagner ce côté là et dire aux militaires
francophones vous savez hull avait mal
pris la fermeture du collège militaire
de saint jean c'était comme de dire ça
va être créée c'est maintenant pour un
anglophone de devenir officier les cours
vont se donner en anglais tout ça c'est
une façon de dire d'avoir à tout le
monde au québec bennoo pour nous
l'important il serait important que des
officiers francophones mais pour dans
une ville militaire dans un comté où il
ya une grosse base militaire ça va avoir
des grosses fesses
dernière question on va la faire
rapidement celle ci ce sondage donne
tronics aujourd'hui fort intéressant qui
montre que 60% des électeurs qui
pourraient voter npd ou libérales
seraient prêts à changer parties en
autant que ça puisse bloquer les
conservateurs qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire on va faire rapidement je
commençais par manon comme réaction le
vote stratégique à quelque chose de très
difficile à faire sauf qu'ici on a un
sondage qui a été fait de façon étendue
dans une trentaine de circonscriptions
où ça bouge beaucoup les écarts sont
minces
et ça c'est intéressant parce que c'est
rare que les électeurs ont un outil
comme celui là pour essayer de diriger
et orienter leur choix
donc il faut avoir seulement un effet
mais les voies stratégiques et quelque
chose très haut perry c'est bien dans ce
but là que ça a été ça a été commandée
par une organisation qui se bat pour le
vote et rappelé les 20 dernières
secondes avec vos michel les gens qui
votent choix libéral soit 1 [ __ ] ont comme
premier réflexe de vouloir battre c'est
vraiment heureux ils sont prêtes à
changer de parti pour la plupart d'entre
eux sauf pour une vieille base libérale
ou une vieille base npd alors il est
clair que dans la dernière semaine si un
des deux parties vraiment montre une
avance qui est réel sur l'autre qui va y
avoir une érosion vert sur tartines j'ai
interrogé
maintenant quand eli merci beaucoup au
revoir